[Música]
realidades heróis o futuro do país
realidades herói o futuro do país
essas palavras parecem meio de conexões
mas se eu disser pra vocês que eu estava
absolutamente conectados
quando falo de heróis eu não falo de um
super homem ou de uma mulher maravilha
apesar desses heróis de certa forma se
encaixarem com as idéias que eu trago
aqui hoje mas quando falo de heróis
eu falo de heróis do cotidiano homens e
mulheres que nos ajudaram as exatamente
no lugar que a gente dá hoje a conhecer
ói na vida de vocês
quem foi essa pessoa é essencial para
que você fosse exatamente quem você é
hoje vou fazer um convite a gente
refletir sobre realidades heróis sobre o
futuro do país e como cada uma dessas
coisas se conecta com a realidade
antes de a gente começar a falar de
realidades eu acho importante a gente
refletir qual é o lugar que você ocupa
no mundo lugar que você ocupa no mundo
agora quando eu provoco vocês pensarem
sobre o lugar que você ocupa no mundo eu
quero que vocês pensem qual é o contexto
social de vocês quem foram os página 6
quem foram a os familiares a família de
vocês que oportunidades eles tiveram e
que oportunidade você barulho ajuda
alimentar da apresentação é quando eu
penso sobre o lugar que ocupava quando
eu era um jovem adolescente era um jovem
negro que tinha nascido nascido e criado
no subúrbio do rio de janeiro acho que
deu para perceber um pouco pelo mesmo
técnico eu sou carioca elza era o filho
mais novo de quatro irmãos e os meus
irmãos não tinham tido acesso à
universidade
na verdade nenhum dos meus irmãos pisou
o pé no ensino superior
essa era a minha realidade inicial é o
que eu vou chamar aqui pra vocês
realidades era a realidade é zero é o
seu ponto de partida
a gente não tem controle nenhum sobre a
nossa realidade diz a verdade a gente
não tem controle nenhum e para algumas
pessoas a realidade é zero é
completamente cheia de privilégios
é como se tudo caminhar se para que
essas pessoas conseguissem alcançar o
sucesso
mas pra outras pessoas e eu acho que
para a maior parte dos brasileiros
a realidade é zero é cheia de obstáculos
é como se tudo caminhar se hoje jamais
saísse dessa realidade ela já se
realidade diz ela
quando eu penso no lugar que ocupava
enquanto jovem negro nascido e criado o
subúrbio do rio de janeiro
eu penso que tudo caminhava para que eu
nunca saí da realidade onde eu penso que
eu cresci e vivi numa sociedade é um
marcado pelo racismo na sociedade o que
eu ou pessoas parecidas comigo
dificilmente serão representadas nas
universidades
dificilmente civil representada a gente
na política os espaços de poder
mas ainda assim essas pessoas eram
maioria entre os analfabetos
essas pessoas eram maioria entre as
pessoas viviam em extrema pobreza
eu digo eram mas isso ainda é a
realidade do nosso país e que tipo de
realidade eu enquanto jovem negro
nascido na zona norte do rio de janeiro
o dia pensar no futuro que não fosse
aquela realidade que todo mundo me fazer
acreditar que era a única que tinha
acesso mas ainda assim eu sonhava grande
ainda assim eu queria ser professor e
queria ser professor universitário e ser
professor significava para a minha
chance de poder influenciar a vida de
pessoas
eu lembro quando eu era pequeno eu
brincava que eu era um professor que
dava aos meus alunos imaginários
eu basicamente falando sozinho com os
meus alunos que estavam fora da cabeça
eu queria ser professor para influenciar
a vida de pessoas e essa é a realidade
que imaginava para o futuro isso vou
chamar aqui de realidade um
tão diferente da realidade a 0 é dadá
que você não tem nenhum impacto na
realidade um é algo que você projeta
para o seu futuro
realidade 0 realidade quando eu penso na
minha realidade sabem da minha realidade
um daquela época elas eram completamente
diferente e eu atribuo essa diferença é
que essa realidade tinham a minha mãe e
um impacto tão grande que ela teve na
minha vida a minha mãe ela nasceu e
cresceu no peru baixo é uma comunidade
na periferia de salvador
aos 18 anos ela se mudou para o rio de
janeiro
ela já era mãe de um filho que é o meu
irmão mais velho e ela foi para o rio de
janeiro para trabalhar como doméstica
trabalhar em casa de família com
cozinheira a minha mãe assim como todas
as minhas x e as grandes referências que
eu tive na minha vida era uma mulher
negra forte e foi a mulher que fez com
que eu sou boa parte do que eu sou hoje
quando eu penso no impacto que a minha
mãe teve na minha vida eu penso que ela
influenciou a minha realidade um de
vocês pararem para pensar a minha
realidade era a mesma a gente crescia
acordava cedo ela ia para o trabalho eu
continuava na escola me arrumava para
refletir qual voltava nada tinha mudado
mas o que eu projetava para o futuro
graças à minha mãe era completamente
diferente daquela realidade eu vivi a
minha mãe me deu a auto-estima para
acreditar que eu era capaz de alcançar
qualquer que fosse o objetivo que eu
estava no meu caminho e quando falo de
heróis paulo exatamente dessas pessoas
essas pessoas que nos fazem acreditar e
realidades diferentes
essas pessoas que nos fazem acreditar
que nós somos capazes de alcançar essa
realidade diferente
quem foi o herói na vida de vocês
quando eu penso nos heróis eu cruzei com
muitos ao longo da minha vida uns por
uma grande parte da minha história
outros por um tempo muito curto
herói e aí eu acho que é isso que me
traz exatamente principal hoje porque
boa parte dos exemplos de heróis que
conheceu conheci aqui no pará
é eu trabalhei chega a chance de
trabalhar aqui no pará em 2016 e começou
a minha história de amor por esta terra
o pará é eu vim para trabalhar por meio
de uma organização chama petrobrasil que
a organização coloca jovens promissores
para trabalharem no setor público um a
dois anos
e aí eu fui colocado para trabalhar na
secretaria de educação do pará
e aí pára pra pensar comigo educação já
estava mais ou menos nos meus planos
eu sabia que era o que eu precisava para
influenciar a vida de outras pessoas
sair do eixo rio-são paulo de certa
forma também estava nos meus planos
porque era a única forma de conseguir
conhecer os verdadeiros desafios do país
agora me mudar do rio de janeiro para
belém do pará
isso definitivamente não estava na minha
realidade um desafio que eu aceitei e
que certamente foi uma das melhores
experiências que o time leve maniçoba
deixem o tucupi o filhote no tucupi o
sotaque paraense
o calor paraense muito calor para esse
tudo isso foi o que me fez me apaixonar
por essa terra inclusive foi nessa terra
que encontrei os maiores exemplos de
heróis lembra que para vocês porque na
secretaria de educação
cada uma das pessoas que trabalhava lá e
dava como os maiores desafios da
educação aqui no pará é complexidade
tudo é difícil a infraestrutura da
escola de formação de professores
logística imagina a logística no estado
as proporções como é o nosso estado
parado tudo é um desafio mas ainda assim
não encontrava pessoas que acordavam
todos os dias
pegavam augusto montenegro quem conhece
belém pará sabe que pegar augusto
montenegro de manhã em si já é uma
jornada do herói
as pessoas chegavam do trabalho e
acreditavam apesar de tudo e tudo ali
naquele momento falava pra elas que as
coisas não iam dar certo e ainda assim
elas trabalhavam porque elas sabiam que
ela tinha um compromisso de criar
realidades novas jovens para estes a
experiência de trabalhar com educação do
pará foi extremamente importante para
mim porque
aprendi duas grandes lições a primeira
delas à educação o maior super poder que
existe porque a educação e nos permite
sair de realidade e 0 e materializar
realidades 1
a outra lição que aprendi aqui no pará
foi que os verdadeiros heróis de nosso
país são os profissionais de educação
porque são eles que têm o poder de fazer
com que os nossos jovens se vejam capaz
de alcançar qualquer seja o objetivo que
eles põem lá na realidade um dele quando
eu penso nessa experiência que eu tive
no pará
eu penso nesses heróis do cotidiano
heróis que fazem com que os nossos
jovens sejam capazes de enxergar esses
objetivos apesar de qualquer que seja
obstáculo e se lembra que eu falei
realidades heróis o futuro do país
será que ele estava tudo conectado
realmente está porque quando esses
heróis da educação fazem com que os
nossos jovens acreditem os seus próprios
futuros
eles fazem com que realidade diferente
sejam possíveis para o nosso país
quando eles fazem essa realidade seja
diferente para o nosso país
é aí que a gente começa a criar cada um
dos passos que a gente dá pra chegar no
brasil que a gente quer o brasil que a
gente tem representantes que de fato os
representa o brasil em que a educação de
qualidade não é um privilégio de poucos
no brasil que o jovem de pele preta como
eu consigam se ver representados
universidades na política ou qualquer
que seja o espaço no brasil que as
nossas crianças acreditam que são
capazes de alcançar o seu sonho
eu queria muito que vocês saírem daqui
com 13 mensagens em mente
a primeira dessas mensagens é que você
precisa saber qual é a sua realidade um
você precisa saber aonde você quer
chegar
isso é extremamente importante porque no
momento em que você tem clareza da onde
você quer chegar
você garante que o nosso país como um
todo consiga ir para lugares diferentes
a outra mensagem que eu queria que vocês
saírem daqui é a mensagem de que vocês
precisam acreditar
o potencial de vocês para alcançar
qualquer que seja realidade
isso é muito importante porque no
momento em que você acredita na sua
capacidade de alcançar qualquer que seja
realidade
você permite todos nós enquanto
brasileiros também conseguimos caminhar
com essa realidade
a última mensagem que eu queria deixar
para vocês é que todos nós é cada um de
nós pode ser pode ser não é um
verdadeiro era isso que a gente tem o
compromisso é eu digo o compromisso de
fazer com que os nossos jovens alcancem
qualquer que seja seu objetivo
nós temos o compromisso de fazer com que
os nossos filhos primos sobrinhos e nos
netos consigam se vê como capaz de
alcançar qualquer que seja o seu futuro
independente a realidade da série c no
ano muito importante para todos nós é um
ano em que a gente vai decidir que
realidade a gente quer para os próximos
quatro anos
é um ano que a gente tem que assumir a
nossa responsabilidade de nas urnas
escolher o brasil que a gente quer ter e
por isso nós do que nunca
qual é a realidade de vocês hoje é
realidade onde vocês querem chegar
amanhã e mais importante não é a
realidade que você o que nós brasileiros
podemos começar a construir redor
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]